in the documentation for async tasks we
can scroll down to the section that
talks about protected methods here we
see that different methods are called on
the UI thread first is on the background
thread
it also contains information on what
order these methods are called in
relative to the do and background method
for example on pre execute gets called
on the UI thread before doing background
so with that information now we can
populate the answers to our quiz as we
mentioned before on pre execute happens
on the main thread and here you can do
any setup work then doing background
happens on the background thread while
this is running you can actually call
published progress as many times as you
want so that you can pass information to
the UI so that it can update and then
tell the user that a certain percentage
of the work is done each time this is
called it triggers on progress update
with some information then you can show
a loading indicator in your UI that says
somethings 10% done 50% done 100% done
and all this happens on the main thread
and then once all of this is complete in
the background thread then it calls on
post execute with the results on the
main thread